peu
[Musique]
1623 sous le règne de louis xiii
armand duplessis cardinal de richelieu
vient de promulguer un édit interdisant
le guen qui décimait la fine fleur des
nobles et spasmes
c'était dit prévoyez la peine de mort
pour les contrevenants mais cette
jeunesse orgueilleuse avide de gloire ne
se soucier guerre d edith de monsieur le
cardinal ni à cardio et en celui de la
comté effet dieu sait quelle monfils ce
long entretien
[Musique]
attention par ordre du roa et son
éminence messieurs les duellistes
veuillez nous suivre à la prison de
bastia ce soit du cardinal
[Applaudissements]
ces gens sont partis reprenons au soir
audi cette fois le jeune aura plus
[Musique]
voilà regard du cardinal nous sommes
humains qui la bat rendu avec monsieur
martin ego commence at-il déjà vous aura
entendu me provoquer martine écho au
duel et on vous sera dénoncé police du
cardinal est décidément bien fait
elles font chuter paris aux affaires
sans un sou et où aller chez parce que
d'ars peut-être alors sange est parti
cette nuit pour ses terres dans le berry
le berry le désert enfin soit pour le
berry
il
[Musique]
et
que se passe-t-il vous chers amis je
n'hésite pas et pas vous revoir si tôt
j'ai un service à vous demander prenez
le cheval de ce gentilhomme monté avec
moi nous serons mieux proposée
comprenait ma terreur sévérité des
cardinal va se manifester de terribles
manière et il vaut mieux ne pas être de
ceux à qui elle s'appliquera ouais je
vous comprends hélas je me rends au fête
donnée pour la naissance du fils de
prince de condé et je vais être absent
trois semaines et vous pas quelques
faire mouche pourrait attendre de vous
recevoir dans une ferme vous plaisantez
un ami tels que vous non je vous
conduirai chez un ami un cousin vous y
serez en sécurité
parfait mais je vous dois d'être au
programme aussi avec votre permission je
prendrai le nom de
mais
et
mais charité ce coupé la charité
encore encore jamais marché non mario
sont des seigneurs ils ont droit de me
tuer mais nous ne pouvons pas leur jeter
depuis
[Musique]
amy infâmes que venu
mercedes ne comprend pas la langue de
veau seigneurie comment t'appelles-tu
bonhomme la flèche pour vous servir
monsieur dix mois que vous cette
mercedes 1 c'est une bonne fille qui ne
demande qu'à connaître le nom de vos
ségneré afin de prier pour elle pour
celui de prier pour nous sans nous
nommer le bon dieu nous connaît bien
[Musique]
cette place là
sociaux
prenez le chemin de bois doré bois doré
c'est le nom du cousin qui je vous amène
redorer attendait une espagne hérétiques
ne voit plus que le ferons a ri et s'est
convertie en même temps que lui et pas
mieux peut-être ça sonne comme une
vieille chaise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
j'habitais
rien rien avant d'avoir terminé cette
source
[Musique]
oh
voilà enfin notre quatre heures
[Musique]
cela m'a donné faim
vraiment une belle jarczyk
[Musique]
il
trop
[Musique]
infatigable pays alors bel âge il faut
en prendre votre parti à cet âge un
homme fait tout pour se prouver à lui
même qu'il a toujours 23 jalouse
loin de moi cette chance j'ai de plus en
plus fins
monsieur noir qui me lie à une lettre
pour vous au château vous l'avez vous
apporter non non il ya si longtemps que
monsieur marc il en a reçus de cette
personne mais j'ai pensé qu'il n'y avait
pas d'urgence mais qui s'agit-il
mademoiselle de boeuvres évidemment
non rien
[Musique]
oh
vous ne pouviez pas lui annoncer la
nouvelle avec une ménagement je m'en
moque bien déménagement ménagement
[Musique]
nous
et
l'attaqué
[Musique]
seul marqué mon cher marquer
chers amis
mon ami
on deux amis
et
[Musique]
mais
un ennemi
voici deux ans déjà que cet horrible
guerre vous a éloigné de moi nouvel
actros m'ont fait croire à votre mort
désespoir et sur les instances de mon
père
je vais donc épousé monsieur 2
c'est un mariage de convenance en clair
est demeuré
lauriane
[Musique]
veuf depuis six mois
je me sens en fin de droit de vous
écrire je serai en bois doré dans le
courant du mois
en route vers le château de mon père
ouji attendra la fin de mon deuil mon
coeur se réchauffe à la pensée de vous
savoir vivant et à celle aussi de revoir
l'ami de mon enfance
[Musique]
car ce réseau validé
il ya celle aussi de revoir
[Musique]
la mine monde en force
comme l'est son dos et vous vous semblez
tout bouleverser tenez
nous l'avait pas dit j'avais lu dans les
astres qu'une nouvelle importante
réjouira bientôt votre coeur la peste
soit les astres n'êtes-vous pas heureux
vous avez pleuré de la savoir marier et
voilà maintenant qu'elle est libre et
qu'elle est de retour
j'ai 30 ans de plus qu'elle
j'interrogerai les astres pour plus de
sûreté
mais dès maintenant je pense que la
conjonction doit être la teste de votre
conjonction des gardes de loi l'image
d'un cavalier au visage lisse aux yeux
limpide même ratel encore avec ça si
elle vous a aimé elle vous aimera tels
que vous êtes
on est tous sur elle a eu dans son lit
un mari qu'elle n'aimait pas peut-être
mais qui avait l'haleine fraîche le
matin la police et même s'il n'avait pas
d'intérêt pour elle mais sait-on jamais
avec les femmes
il avait davantage de jeanne et non
point rugueux comme moi vous exagérez
mon ami je fais encore illusion mais
dans un an dans deux tandis ce sera en
plein épanouissement de saboter ses sens
seront plus exigeants encore mais moi
j'aurai assez de farce dans les bras
pour ployer sa taille parce que je la
désirais
soyez optimiste oui vous êtes encore
capables de tendre ce tisonnier et plus
tard je ne veux pas lui donner l'image
d'un vieux mari impuissant carpediem
voudra-t-elle de moins encore avec ce
visage de gargouilles et puis qui est
elle après deux années m t-elle encore
les mêmes livres après en avoir donné
les goûts peut-être sonné tel détachées
bon je sais que vous ne met pas beaucoup
cette littérature et c'est pourtant bien
joli je suis soupçonneuse je suis
jalouse je suis difficile à gagner
facile à prendre et plus aisés a offensé
et très malaisée 1re apaisé vous
entendrez cité l'astrée ou non montaigne
boccace rabelais soit mais c'est
préciosité le rien le reflet
je suis soupçonné
je suis jalouse
je suis soupçonneuse
je suis jalouse je suis difficile à
gagner
s'il apprend
[Musique]
difficile à gagner
c'est leur droit
[Musique]
bourguignon yat-il mon enfance je ne
puis vous le dire bourguignon arrêtés
nous ici
ok
[Musique]
loria l'oréal mais cette folle alors
venez me dit vous obtenez dorian c'est
la mort qui ont cherché à attraper les
chez moi mais pourquoi cette folie mon
enfant si j'étais catholique on perd je
la dis ramon confesseur vous êtes
huguenote dieter votre belle je leur
donne eh bien j'avais un instant oublier
que j'étais devenue une femme que
j'avais presque le droit d'avoir de
mauvaises passes mon dieu il n'est pas
terminée loin de là
mais certains hasard me prennent au
dépourvu et provoque en moi des émotions
que je ne peux pas contrôler alors pour
me punir
c'est un drôle de caractère ma fille je
croyais vaut bien connaître puis c'est
je me connaître moi même
les bébés
[Musique]
le marquis ne précise pas lui même à la
distribution
en tout cas je vois avec joie qu'ils
n'oublient pas c'est de voir deux
chrétiens non n'oublie aucun témoin
guerre au confessionnal toi mon enfant
elle en aurait trop par à coups nous
aurions simplement je peux parfois
qu'ils nous ont dit dieu est miséricorde
oui oui mais ses serviteurs les deux
rappeurs du nord jeudi au tpi nigra
[Rires]
critiqueront des gars comme lui remettre
mon enfant le marquis et ils n'ont il
est absent et n'ai pas vu passer son
carrosse pas trop surveillance est
inutile de la victoire bien sûr les
muscles du cou à damas fortifiée ils
soutiennent ceux du visage ainsi les
rides sont moins apparente c'est
supportable en capitaine za massa puis
bon elle devrait donc être à bois doré à
la fin du mois c'est à dire
d'après le calendrier aujourd'hui ou
demain au plus tard aujourd'hui ou
demain alors appuyer les mêmes aléas
puis un pays hall
c'est marqué ce job la sécu raison
[Musique]
la vue d'un homme nu en france tels
votre pudeur directeur à la guerre tous
les morts sont il est vrai que vous
n'avez pas assez la guerre et que les
morts qu'on nous apporte sont
généralement bien enveloppé de prouver
vous faire taire cet instrument merci
soulagera cette musique vous paraît
telle une musique et l'éthique
mon dieu les écossais ont joué ce sont
des huguenots
les bretons aussi y ont joué les
auvergnats je vous en prie comment
appelez vous votre joueur de cornemuse
je plains pourquoi vous voulez qu'ils
vous enseigne de son instrument exemple
un oeil au vél une hausse nouvel i know
you vélidio velino des orphelines audio
du jour velino n'y avait il pas un
astrologue italien célèbre du nom de
dieu ophélie nom et qui comme copernic a
été jugé pour hérésie en italie et qui
dit on aurait trouvé refuge en france
du temps du feu roi henri iv savez vous
aussi s'ils jouaient de la cornemuse
région ce détail mais je marque c'est là
une grande lacune monsieur le recteur
quand on est un bon inquisiteur comme
vous on doit être en possession de
toutes les pièces du dossier avant de
poser des questions indiscrètes moi je
ne suis pas en inquisiteur monsieur
marquis je sers dieu de mon mieux voilà
tout ignace de loyola disait de même les
assassins de la saint-barthélemy aussi
vous parler comme un renégat
à qui la faute je me suis converti parce
que je pensais que votre dogme était
toute charité
d'abord il l'est monsieur le marquis il
l'est il est alors oublions tout les
guerres de religion qui ont déchiré la
france et ne pensons qu'au pardon ça
sera l'atout notre évangile pour
aujourd'hui vous pouvez en faire part à
votre évêque
lauriane déjà
le
les troubles
art
à damas vite mon avis nous avons de la
visite et maintenant lé dinh et monsieur
le recteur
sinon vous allez encore à voir nous de
marquer
vous avez été dur avec le curé en
aquitaine c'est un espion de condé de
l'archevêque de tous ceux qui se méfient
des gens qui comme le roi henri iv ont
jugé que paris allait bien une messe
et si vous l'aviez offensé un chien sur
noah donne du bâton avant qu'ils ne te
mord à fait vrai
bon coup ça on resserre guillaume akoa
dois-je le plaisir du louvre je vous
emmène un ami de paris monsieur de
villarreal j'aimerais que vous le garder
jusqu'à mon retour des fêtes données par
le prince de condé
à ce propos vous n'y allez pas ah non
pas encore non il reste de nos guerres
quelques petites égratignures qui ne
sont pas encore cicatrisées non non mais
ça me permettra de garder votre ami
j'ai cru voir un rat ici c'est un métal
je me serais trompé
dieu est vraiment bon il a dédommagé ses
anciens ennemis de tout le mal qui lui
en fait en leur laissant leurs richesses
et pour ne pas dire plus ses fidèles
serviteurs comme les vieux habitués
d'une auberge sont toujours servis les
derniers la plus mauvaise table ces mots
de la part de catholiques et vous êtes
ont de quoi il connaît bien la brûler
autant de lui pendant l'inquisition ce
n'est pas pour d'autres raisons que
celles qui s'offre à vos yeux en ce
moment il fallait faire comprendre aux
chrétiens déshérités que les biens de ce
monde ne sont jamais définitivement
acquis ils sont périssables
il vaut mieux l'humilité et la pauvreté
que les flammes du bûcher et vous auriez
l'intention de brûler toutes ces
merveilles
certes s'il s'avérait qu'elle offense
monsieur de villarreal
monsieur je suis leur hector poullet je
vous remercie de votre hospitalité
monsieur j'espère qu'elle ne nous
portera pas malheur malheur oui je
disais à l'instant à votre cousin que je
n'hésiterai pas mettre le feu votre
château si ce geste pouvait être
agréable à dieu je vous rends grâce même
prévenir je dis toujours ce que je pense
fût-ce à contretemps et bien votre
franchise appelle la mienne je suis bon
chrétien bon catholique
monsieur le recteur peut en témoigner
d'ailleurs je lui dois ma conversion mes
compliments mais depuis une petite plus
tard poche
non pas du tout non non je sais que vous
m'aimez paternellement que vous êtes
heureux et fier de me montrer oui dans
le diocèse je suis son plus beau titre
de gloire
d'où votre présence assidue à mes côtés
je vous en remercie et un passant à
table j'espère que mon ordinaire ne
pensera pas le seigneur
[Musique]
non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
voilà fait patienter nos hôtes je viens
de boue siens du bâton quel destin
son mari a été tué aux 6h de nevers
quelques jours après leurs noces dans
une note
on ne peut rien vous cacher convertir
serait une tâche bien agréable monsieur
le marquis n'a point reçu ma lettre qui
n'est point là pour matin je lis niort
madame peut-être est-il à la salle à
manger en train de festoyer avec
quelques amis julie niort madame
[Musique]
savez vous où se trouve silva excusez
moi mais je voulais vous montrer quelque
chose
[Musique]
alors j'ai même encore
as vous connaissez mais j'ai de
villarreal ma fille madame de la mode si
jeune aaron a oublié de me présenter je
suis l'abbé poulain votre nouveau
recteur
j'ai tout monsieur le recteur que madame
ait besoin de vos services
ma fille était did not par les sens elle
est demeurée par son mariage je croyais
avoir appris que des veuves
cela ne change rien à la ferme chez le
recteur en attendant monsieur de bois
doré notre hôte
puis-je vous faire les honneurs d'une
maison que je connais bien j'apprends
votre veuvage et j'en suis fort peiné
pendant je vous remercie monsieur de
votre pitié pitié est un bien grand mot
pour ce farouche catholique de
villarreal
ils pensent au contraire j'en suis sûr
que la mort de votre mari afin d'hériter
de moins j'ai été le possible le
monsieur seriez-vous pour la reprise des
troubles le trouble cela paie
ce mélange ignoble où tout est confondue
est bon les méchants les purs les impurs
les anges avec les bêtes en on ne
parlait pas de la paix seule la guerre
avec ses deux camps bien précis la
guerre seul éclair
quoique choquant pour nous cette
franchise vous honore vous avez parlé
car un véritable soldat du christ
monsieur de villarreal mais j'en suis un
et vous aurez un paroissien de plus
monsieur l'abbé et j'en serai ravi
notre paroisse de la poterie est bien
modeste et j'avoue que nos paysans ne
sont pas présents passé beaucoup parmi
eux ne se sont convertis au catholicisme
que pour échapper au supplice ou à la
fin pour monsieur de bois de renault
trucks le cas et est bien différent et
monsieur bonhomme est un soldat il a
oublié son roi c'est de bois doré les
thèmes de guerre il a fait toutes les
campagnes du feu roi henri iv postes les
plus exposés
[Musique]
le terrain n'était c'est l'éternité que
je viens de vivre ensemble
[Musique]
bonjour mon ami c'est assez
maître georges l'a un peu de musique
dino gaiement
[Musique]
mais hommage à madame les trois semaines
qui vont encore me séparer de vous vont
me paraître interminable bon séjour chez
rami et ne mettez pas le feu
le gage madame que vous rêvez d'un amour
vrai tels que vous pourriez l'inspiré un
galant tonnes non pas d'une comédie
comme vous lâche monsieur de baudre et
je sais c'est dans la photo regarde moi
il faut partir les eaux gonflées mêmes
pourront pas passer le guembri bien me
faire
merci mon xativa bonnet lauriad
et puis chez vous
maintenant venu monsieur le recteur
monter dans mon corps dépendant de
chrétiens voilà plus de deux ans que
j'attends cette soirée et nous nous
sommes pas parlé parlé parlé à qui un
masque
pourquoi silva
pourquoi cette mascarade
comment vous répondre ne sortez points
la pluie pourrait faire couler votre
maquillage
[Musique]
m
l'homme violent et au delà francesca
radiosat pourquoi pas michel-ange et
léonard de vinci m'ont dit nous on
dirige mode ironique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
piti grâce je te reconnais la flèche
monseigneur marc lire ça tu peux
malhonnête et qui mérite seulement
quelques coups de bâton en conscience
vincou perd largement mon petit désordre
tu es entré ici la tendance est bien
temps dans a permis un autre de passer
la nuit dans la grange et on glisse de
reconnaissance tuer c'est devenu quelque
chose tu mériterais qu'elle statue sur
la juste un petit peu fouineur et que
chercher
par ma vie contre un secret d'abord le
secret alors ce secret si vous enlevez
votre taille
ce sera plus facile à vous expliquer je
n'ai pas vraiment de secret monseigneur
mais un trésor énorme
les trésors de guerre d'une ue le secret
c'est l'endroit où il est caché chansons
le maître de ces lieux catholique
comment pourrait-il être en possession
du trésor des huguenots où j'étais moi
même prisonnier d une nos dents surtout
alors que le roi ne se convertisse j'ai
vu entrer ici de des chariots des
chariots de butin il en a mis partout
dans les caves dans les greniers
ça c'est le butin du pld d'église vous
voyez que j'avais raison
si boire les chats ne les croit alors où
en amont et il reste ses tableaux comme
ses meubles dans le château mais où l'on
tue le cacher ça tu ne seras jamais mais
moi oui
allez va tant que je n'entende plus
parler de toi
si tu me rencontrer un jour fait celui
qui ne m'a jamais vu monseigneur
n'aurait-il pas une petite box pourra
pas aux acrobates
je te laisse la vie c'est plus qu'une
mérite
j'ai remarqué
cher marionnettes on en a des secrets
[Musique]
t
que faites vous ici malades
à cette heure je n'avais pas sommeil
je pensais que que vous non plus
un peu de lecture vous faudra tel
plaisir et c'est pour me faire la
lecture que vous vous êtes ainsi paré
vos lectures préférées sont las tres et
le grand timide les princesses ils
jouent des rôles de bergères j'ai pensé
que le contraire pourrez vous amuser
aussi
[Musique]
je remercie blindes des autres
sollicitude j'ai mes comptes de fermage
à faire et je crains de devoir y passer
la nuit
m
venu
bonne nuit chez le marquis
[Musique]
on
que voulez vous
j'ai pu dormir et pourriez-vous me lire
quelques pages de l'astrée pourriez pas
les lire vous même vous avez raison on
fait d'amour l'astrée nos digues des
fadaises alors nous parlons pas d'amour
[Musique]
avi
vous
mairie
[Musique]
j'avais la fin de match tout moi quand
j'ai fait comme moi non tiens mon âge
[Musique]
vous supputer sur les chances de votre
jardin oh non non non je m'interroge sur
son plan je voudrais pouvoir mettre les
parterres en accord avec le chiffre 7
elle vous superstitieux qui ne tenait
pas quelque peu inconsciemment
non non là n'est pas la question le
chiffre 7 était celui du roi défunt
tenez par exemple n'at-il pas vaincu arc
en septembre le 21 37 son armée n'était
elle pas composé de sept escadrons dont
je commandais le dernier de septième
alors je mets du sed partouze le puits
cela ressemble à de l'idolâtrie ah si
vous aviez connu le roi henri paul
auriez aimé huguenots alors pensée
catholique
oui j'ai fait toutes ces campagnes
puis l'heure de la retraite est venu
la retraite
retraite plaisante retraite quand même
voyez-vous il m arrivait dans la vie 3
chagrin qui m'ont permis de comprendre
que les choses en ce monde ne durait pas
longtemps
le premier c'est la mort de ma mère
le second la mort de mon frère est le
troisième celle du roi tous trois ont
péri de mort violente et je ne m'en
console pas il faut reprendre du service
et repartir à la recherche de quelques
nouveau graal le temps n'est plus pour
ce genre de quête
je sais que de l'otan l'intérêt print ou
alors pourquoi pas la recherche du
trésor de guerre des huguenots vos
anciens amis ils étaient considérables
m'a-t-on dit un peu de gelée de ses
draps merci je mange fort peu le matin
davet grand tort il fait très froid
dehors et vaut mieux avoir l'estomac
bien berné ont ce qui concerne le trésor
des huguenots
ce n'est pas l'heure pour en parler
il faut attendre la veillée et faire
comme les anglais qui raconte au coin du
feu des histoires de fantômes
je vais me faire une promenade à cheval
tout le matin 1 et vous voudrez bien
m'excuser approché m dos plat
[Musique]
on resserre grand ami asseyez vous et
mangez moi une tranche de pâté ou de
jambon comme nous faisons souvent quand
nous sommes en tête à tête qui me fait
trop d'honneur je n'aime pas les
jésuites je veux là si vous aviez connu
notre ancien curé il vous aurez compris
lui n'auriez pas été obligée de traduire
votre nom en français vous seriez
toujours lucci liautaud bellino et non
pas pauvre sonneur de cornemuse trop
peureux encore du slam puisque ici je
vis dans la sécurité et que s'il peut
continuer mes études il faut que je vous
dise oui mon hôte monsieur de villarreal
vient de me faire une allusion directe
au trésor de guerre des huguenots
je consulterai les astres pour savoir si
ap rivaux menace attention on vient d'un
beau mais son de l'hymne
[Musique]
sange il ya des secrets dans cette
raison je te demande d'ouvrir l'oeil
avant de vous occuper du secret des
autres
songy bien plutôt à défendre le vôtre et
deux choses sont liées
comment cela vient suppose que je porte
au cardinalat enseignement un
renseignement sur ces messieurs de la
religion et quoi tu pas qu'il
m'accordait ma grasse si le
renseignement est important l'est mais
de quoi s'agit-il
les é tat le dire à la lumière du jour
l'histoire me paraît un peu fantastique
ce serait bien autrement mais je connais
quelqu'un qui m'éclaircir a les idées
à
et
[Musique]
je de villarreal
je l'aï fait
mais monfils s'il sent tranquille
monsieur le recteur je voulais derrière
subodorer jeune et très touché par
l'accueil et j'avais l'impression d'être
dans un repaire de huguenots jeux de
bois doré et catholiques prime de
fraîche date
on est il moins bon vous croyez à ces
catholiques l'âme soeur
je crains qu'il ne ressemble à la à la
nes de ma cousine
oui cette bête avait la nano un jour on
enferme son petit ont la charge de tout
ce qu'il fallait pour déjeuner sur
l'herbe à la campagne elle va bien
jusqu'à la moitié du chemin du tout à
coup elle se elle se souvient de son
annonce ces trois sont en arrière vous
jette toutes les provisions voilà dans
la rivière et s'en retourne sans que
rien ni personne ne puisse le retenir
je voyais j'espère l'application l'armée
n'y a rien à reprocher à monsieur de
bois doré il est très charitable il
distribue beaucoup de monde sans vous
consulter je parie peu importe
oui mais n'est-ce pas apparemment je
veux dire cette couverture ne
cache-t-elle pas à secret de grande
importance à secrets politiques pour pau
que pensez vous de son entourage 1
eh bien au juste un homme bien suspecte
ce joueur de cornemuse vois que vous
avez flairé le père il me semble être un
personnage que l'on essaie de cacher ses
pourrait être un grand prêtre d'une
société secrète bien encore le chef
une organisation clandestine et c'est
aussi mon opinion je n'ai jamais pu
acquérir la certitude il ya autre chose
autre chose
oui d'une importance considérable de
cela non plus je ne suis pas sûr mais
j'ai de fortes présomptions monsieur de
bois doré a passé sa vie à faire la
guerre et qui dit guerre des pillages
but un trésor caché
monsieur de villarreal puis la charge de
ce diocèse
comprenez-moi bien et je dois employer
toutes les méthodes pour y assurer la
paix même si ses méthodes par est
indigne d'un serviteur de dieu quand ton
sérieux
peu importe la méthode une personne de
bois doré qui servi autrefois chez les
catholiques m'affirme avoir reconnu
certaines pièces de collection qu'il
avait connue chez ses anciens maîtres et
que la retrouver précisément à bois doré
si ce qu'affirme cette personne ivre il
s'agit sans aucun doute du trésor de
guerre des huguenots plus recherché en
vain depuis des années le cardinal et
monsieur le prince de condé qui me fait
nommer ici c'est le prince lui même qui
m'a demandé de placer à mon tour cette
personne chez bois doré afin de pénétrer
dans son intimité
si vous voulez bien me comprendre et
essayer ainsi de percer le secret
et cette personne bien entendu ces dames
de l'être
[Musique]
monsieur le marquis je vous conseille ce
phare il est plus foncée il paraîtra
plus naturel non mais t'es pas trop
madame de la mode saillie vous prendrait
pour un gamin de l'âne voilà un nom que
je n'aime pas vous entendre prononcer ni
par quiconque
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi vous obstinez vous à vouloir
ressembler aux héros de vos romans
j'ai compris que l'amour de lauriane est
à jamais refusé demain je ferai venir
les maçons et je leur ferai mur et la
porte de la pièce où sont enfermés les
souvenirs de ma passion
[Musique]
votre corps a été assurée de blessures
au cours des guerres et vous ne souffrez
pas une égratignure faite par le regard
d'une femme non mais qu'attendez vous
pour aller la trouver et lui poser la
question qui vous brûle les lèvres
auriez vous peur de la réponse
[Musique]
la grotte on la construit raïssi inhalé
de statues représentant l'amour sous
toutes ses formes y mènera
mais
y'aura laisse-moi l'attend le désirent
la déception l'espoir renaissant
[Musique]
vous vous changez l'ordonnancement de
votre jardin j'allumais au goût du jour
[Musique]
je regretterai celui ci
je vous ai connu galopant sur un poney
je vous avais donné il faut vivre avec
son temps sylvain les femmes vont
reprendre leur place pendant la guerre
nous avons été souvent obligés de nous
déguiser en homme de mon village sera
lui dormir dans la paille mais
maintenant c'est fini nous pouvons
retourner à la swa yo dentelle et vous
occuper de votre jardin
le mot n'est que je mentais comme un
garçon
moore silva
j'en ai eu beaucoup de chagrin mon mari
soldat est mort au siège de maire
je n'en ai vu aucun chagrin
vous en conclurez que je mets plus mon
enfance que mon état de femme
vous auriez tort si la vérité
c'est que je ne suis pas fait pour le
mariage le mariage engendre l habitude
et les habitudes
conduite à la vulgarité
[Musique]
attendre
pensez à l'être cher
l'espère et je crois finalement que
c'est ce qu'il ya de mieux dans l'amour
je vous remercie lorient au m'éloigner
de vous avec beaucoup de délicatesse
je ne veux pas vous éloigner de moi
[Musique]
je comprend à demi mot vous vous trompez
j'ai vu le musée laurier à nawa doré m
jovelin me l'a montré
voilà sylvain comme je veux être aimé
oubliez ce que je vous ai dit l'autre
soir
j'aime aussi les efforts que vous faites
pour vous rajeunir c'est une belle
preuve d'amour que de se défigurer ainsi
pour essayer de plaire à la femme que
l'on aime un jour cependant je vous
demanderai de cécile emploi de ses
phares ce sera le jour où j'accepterais
de devenir votre femme car c'est bien ce
que vous voulez une espace il va que je
devienne votre femme
[Musique]
mais pour cela il vous faudra être
patient attendre longtemps peut-être
je ne veux pas d'un mariage bâclé comme
le dernier je veux être sûr de la pureté
de la force des sentiments que j'inspire
je vous attendrai lauriane il faut
mettre nos coeurs à l'épreuve
jules et d'argene a demandé dix ans de
patience à son amant moi je ne vous en
demanderait que sept
sept ans pourquoi cet antre
7 c'est bien votre chiffre
dans cet homme je serai un vieillard que
m'importe si vous m'aimez cet homme
lauriane et son gérant
ce temps serez vous capable de me faire
ce sacrifice
j'aime ce qui exaltait l'âme et le coeur
[Musique]
j'aime le sublime
tâche au service compris la femme
j'écoute
maigre pitance
vous l'avez pas rencontrer une troupe de
200 soldats non et si je pars le routier
vers être non non nous venons de la
ferté et nous pouvons vous assurer que
nous n'avons pas rencontré la moindre
trou vous pouvez sans hésiter prendre
une autre direction
né dont vous chauffer à l'autre voudrait
prendre au froid nous avons promis de
donner le spectacle au village voisin
on va être en retard moi je m'occupe de
la plus frileuse
[Rires]
pourquoi médicament particulier de
batteries aux ordres du médecin
[Rires]
[Musique]
nos amis
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
[Rires]
key
[Musique]
yahoo
bakou
[Musique]
à
en
[Musique]
c'est
berlin
[Musique]
tous
m
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pourquoi
et
actu rien à faire ici hi hi fi
tiens
[Musique]
l'histoire et ses misérables et amassé
vous blesser sinon c'est moi qui vais
vous prendre à cette branche et remercie
le ciel de ne pas avoir été sur mes
terres sinon c'était la mort pour tous
[Musique]
le garçon est gravement blessé à la main
à son nom le château
[Musique]
maudit basque
je trouverais centre est
[Musique]
je trouverais très sain
aller quérir mais très vite
[Musique]
ce garçon n'a pas du tout l'air d'un
poème bien toi qui connais bien les
morisques qu'en penses tu à damas et
vous avez raison il est allé comme
quelqu'un qui court les routes mais il a
le nez droit le front dégagé rien à vos
risques m je veux l'un usé de toute
votre science pour soigner ce garçon
[Applaudissements]
des blessures superficielles rien de
cassé je m'occupe je vous fais confiance
demain il n'y paraîtra plus un bonne
nuit
merci veiller sur lui au bon je ne peux
plus payer si tu as surtout qu'après
m'être battue
[Musique]
au contraire on va vous soigner
nous courons un truc à tanger à bois
doré personnes étant branché
merci
[Musique]
où
nous
[Musique]
tous
ah oui en train d'avoir vu monsieur
loger chez vous des morisques des
mahométans ma foi il ma religion
m'interdit de loger sous le même toit
que ces maudits j'arrêtais à moi
monsieur m'interdit de jeter dehors une
femme seule est un jeune garçon blessé
tous ces gens sont des voleurs et des
bandits qu'ils me vole monsieur qu'ils
me veulent mais que je dorme
c'est une journée très fatigante venu et
monsieur bonne nuit
monsieur le marquis ne fait pas sa
prière fait là pour moi de masse comme
d'habitude
oui ça y va
la terrible
je voulais joely et comme vous avez
raison il soigne et le jeune haut risque
avec la même compétence
il habitait de ses médecins a rappelé
que nous allons enfin chassé l'espagne
car cela serait en cachant ce savant
monsieur de bois doré comme une faute
par grimm dizier pas de même l'autre
jour un dieu sans doute ne m'inspire
t'il pas de la même manière ce matin et
vos recherches au sujet du trésor
ressente elle au même point sauf que je
me suis grâce à vous fait une alliée en
la personne de dames belin c'est parfait
laissez lui dont le soin de mener à bout
cette enquête
mais non mais ne soyez pas déçus j'ai
parlé de votre foi monsieur le prince
elle voudrait vous employez une autre
mission
comment il abandonne la recherche du
trésor de nouveau
moi non on ne peut pas aller mais
rassurez-vous les deux choses peuvent
fort bien des pères que pensez-vous de
lauriane de la mode suit le prince
envisagerait sur ce parti pour moi
faudra la convertir à moins que 100
calvinisme ne souhaite un prétexte pour
la laisser vivre seul autour de son
manoir lui plaisait vous qu'importe ne
s'agit pas d'une aventure mais de
mariage c'est le père qu'il faudrait
convaincre mariage lui rendrait la
tranquillité il a déjà eu maille à
partir avec les jésuites
si la guerre reprenait et c'est
précisément ce que craint de monsieur le
prince vous seriez en tant que gendre de
monsieur de perdre au centre des
complots un observateur idéal vous
seriez même admirablement place et si la
nécessité s'en faisait sentir
pour exercer un moyen de pression à
travers lauriane sur son père au même
dieu
ne voulait ainsi le grand intéressante
entre vos mains vos fils legrand adhérer
dorian n'est pas ce pantin de bois doré
qui m'ont déjà la gran canaria
[Musique]
il
[Applaudissements]
et
lauriane mademoiselle de veuves enfin je
veux dire madame de la mode séries l et
je ne suis pas si mal
c'est moi lauriane j'en ai pour un
instant l'oréal mais inutile de vous
faire dès ce sont des reproches que je
suis venu vous faire enfin sylvain
qu'est ce que j'apprends par des paysans
cours chez moi monsieur le marquis de
bois doré se bat contre des êtres dix
fois supérieur en nombre les mettant en
fuite ont pris de mes prouesses en
sommes on risque sa vie et tout cela
pour quoi
pour sauver une banque de bohémiens au
oui vous êtes moment où en plus ne vous
suffit plus de vous faire des pour
tenter de vous rajeunir qui vous font
plus agir comme un jeune fou si je vous
avais perdu
si vous étiez mort dans ce combat et des
cils
muet orateur
[Musique]
j'en suis sûr
autre inquiétude pour ma vie
vous êtes très vives
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr que je vous aime et je crois
qu'il va nous falloir refaire la carte
du tendre
oui oui je marquais
non monsieur de villarreal vous arrivé à
point nommé pour régler un différend
lauriane et moi nous divertissons à
refaire la carte du temps oui celle de
l'hôtel de rambouillet ne me plaît pas
du tout elle n'est pas à la mesure d'un
sujet aussi important nous c'est un
continent où nous faisons une amérique
avec ses fleuves et ses forêts immenses
ses montagnes ses déserts
vous voyez nous n'avons pas lésiné avec
le désert le désert c'est la tante et
puis au loin tout au fond un océan bleu
comme espoir un immense océan pacifique
jusqu'ici nous étions d'accord sylvain
et moi
voici où nous ne séparons doit-on mettre
une île dans cet océan
oui au contraire les laisser pur
immatériels comme l'espoir et moi je
n'ai aucune compétence en cette matière
et je le regrette mais je m'étonne qu'un
homme de guerre comme vous puisse
prendre plaisir à de telles passe temps
et pourquoi pas on peut rompre des
lances toute la journée et se retrouver
le soir à genoux auprès de saddam
comme nos ancêtres qu'il est temps que
les peuples heureux est enfin une
histoire sinon il retourne à l'agitation
et au tumulte il faut donc une
distraction puissante et de nos jours ça
ne peut être que la découverte du coeur
mais pourquoi parce que le coeur était
inconnu avant que les précieuses 200
soit
occuper convives est à sa frontière les
dames sont pour moi incompréhensible est
en effet mal aux ailes d'argene à
imposer à son fiancé 10 ans d'attentes
c'est une épreuve et pendant ce temps le
temps passe mais qu'importe le temps
pour ma part je ne demande qu'une heure
si elle est parfaite
j'ai toujours aimé le sort de ces
éphémères
vous savez ces mouches blanches qui se
regroupent autour des lumières les soirs
d'été
gravier si courte
qu'elle semble décharger de tous les
soucis vulgaire comme celui de se
nourrir
que respirer
de se reproduire même peut-être
[Musique]
juste
aimer
mourir
est ce pas merveilleux pour ma part
madame nulle part et en aucun cas je
n'ai plus supporter la galanterie
j'ai toujours détesté ce langage fleuri
mais depuis ce matin grâce à vous je ne
le trouve plus grotesque et je vous
remercie d'avoir permis à un espagnol
d'accéder au sommet de la pensée
française
[Musique]
nous
6 364 jours
perrin
cinq minutes 30 secondes si vous ne
recommencez pas à vous battre praille
de demain
après demain
un mois
elle n'a
je vous attends ok
il
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
guy me permettez-vous de raccompagner
madame de la motte tilly jusqu'à sa
demeure fait cher ami fait mon seigneur
ne vous laissez pas voler la femme que
vous aimez
[Musique]
oh
où
[Musique]
et
pour
[Musique]
oui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]